you know I've always heard that writing
a manga is a grind and that the
schedules are super insane but I never
thought it was your chapter is still due
even during historic earthquakes and
tsunamis insane for those of you that
don't know in 2011 there was an historic
earthquake and subsequent tsunami that
devastated the country of Japan the 9.0
magnitude earthquake devastated much of
Northern Japan and also caused several
500 mile per hour tsunamis that further
upended the country this single event is
to date one of the most deadly natural
disasters to ever occur in Japan with a
toll of nearly 20 000 people deceased or
missing and from all that during all
that Insanity arakawa says that her
chapter that was Jew that week didn't
have its deadline moved At All by her
own account she would have assumed that
she would have been given leeway on the
deadline given the events that had just
taken place but our Publishers didn't
budge an inch talk about a brutal
industry to work in